let's go back to greece because as we've
been telling you all morning here
manchester united captain harry maguire
he's been in court he has now left
the courtroom um on the neighboring
islands
uh of cyros and our sports correspondent
martha keller is there let's have a
listen
harry harry are you pleased with how
that went
did you did you apologize for what
happened on thursday night harry
you're obviously someone who a lot of
people look up to and respect do you
still feel like you've got that
reputation
harry
are you confident your manchester united
career is still intact
okay so right now he is a free man
um other than that no comment at all but
harry maguire leaving the court there on
suros it's the neighboring island
to mykonos the manchester united
captain um was in court today accused of
assaulting a police officer
in a bar room brawl according to local
police
three men were arrested following a late
night
incident on the island of mykonos that
was last night this morning
harry maguire appearing in court
and no comment apart from that right now
he is
free